ich muss einfach sagen wenn nicht dieses
problem nicht gelöst kriege kommen in
absehbarer zeit erstmal keine videos
mehr halle durch meine lieben freunde
herzlich willkommen zu einem kleinen
block über mich und meine probleme und
eigentlich habe ich überhaupt keinen
bock das auf meinem kanal noch so ein
weiteres komisches kurzes video ist aber
hey hey hey ich hab ein kleines problem
und zwar erst mal ein problem eine
kleine kontrollen einem kompressor
mischpult und ich möchte einfach wenn
ihr gerade zuschaut und ahnung von
recording von mikrofonen von mischpult
von xlr kabel der ganzen kaka hat die
ihr habt die damit dranhängt dann würde
ich mich sehr verbunden fühlen wenn ihr
mir da eventuell weiterhelfen könnte
weil ich finde den internet keine info
dazu
ich begreife es selber nicht und wenn
ich selber eine ahnung hätte würde ich
glaube ich willkommen zum video machen
ich muss einfach sagen wenn ich dieses
problem nicht gelöst kriege kommen in
absehbarer zeit erstmal keine videos
mehr
das kann ja auch nicht sein vorhinein
auf eine tolle beleuchtung jetzt
verzieht sich auf aber hier die die
sonne naja egal ich zeige euch erst mal
ganz kurz aus meinem problem ist und
zwar wirklich wenn ihr davon ahnung habt
ich würde euch so abgüssen wenn jemand
von euch mir die richtige lösung geben
könnte
auf dieses problem wahrscheinlich ist es
was total simples aber ich liebe es
einfach nicht hin da habe ich sogar
extra diese alte canon legria immer
wieder aus der schublade holt und zwar
jetzt nicht sagen apple schweiz für alle
die jetzt einfach unterschreiben apple
ist scheiße kriegt von mir einfach ein
blog oder inka kaufen fresse geworfen
weil daran liegt auf keinen fall weil
das ist einfach ich hab bin mit diesem
rechner seit anderthalb jahren am
arbeiten und von gestern auf heute
morgen geht es auf einmal nicht mehr als
es ist gerade ungelogen es ist gerade 14
uhr 8 und ich sitze hier dran ohne spaß
seit 9 uhr seit fünf stunden verbringen
hinzukriegen alles komplett pc neu
gemacht es liegt nicht am pc
es liegt einfach
an dieser leuchte seht ihr die der
aufmerksame zuschauer liest vielleicht
mal ab und zu die beschreibung ist weißt
du was ich für die krippen hat weil der
täter damals findet tastatur haben oder
firma aus oder dann gefragt da steht ja
immer alles drin
nicht so an equipment habe und ich
beschreibe ich jetzt erstmal ganz kurz
war
ich würde nicht so freuen wenn einer von
euch mir darauf die antwort nennen
könnte weil ich habe einfach überhaupt
keinen plan wie ich sonst weiter
aufnehmen sollen beugen der sache das
hier ist mein mikrofon mit dem ich
aufnehme das ist also mikrofon armen
kann ich so oder ziehen dann ist mein
laptop den könnte ja einfach nur irre
ich hatte ja hier dieses mikrofon und
das ist ein rohde and has a und das geht
in den xl er kabel ich mache ein
komplettes equipment video naja das xl
per kabel geht hier komplett durch durch
die mikrofonarm ihr wti wieder rauskommt
ist darum geht dass sie unterm tisch und
so weiter und so fort und dann mündet
dass wir hinten rein in das moment ich
zeige euch mal was das für mich ist das
ist das thema ich bin komplett und zwar
dieses kabel geht quasi vor dem mikrofon
ich spreche das mikrofon der ton geht
durch das xlr kabel durch den
mikrofonarm durch hinten in das b b 202
das ist so eine tube preamp kompressor
entfacht damit ich mehr möglichkeiten
meine stimme quasi zu bearbeiten das ist
quasi besser anhört das mikrofon geht
auf jeden fall ihr wisst es gerade noch
von dem mikrofon raus das xl rk begeht
dann hier einen input dann stelle ich
hier bei dem mischpult hier so ein paar
sachen um so ein paar hebel drückte
vaduz umbach mainz weiteres fort und
dann gibt es hier aus dem output geht
der nächste er kabel wieder raus und das
geht hier in meinen behring auf 6002 das
geht hier rein und dann habe ich hier
meinen ganzen einstellungen hab hier
beispielsweise den mengenmäßig habe
level ich hab den gehen wo man sagen
kann ok so laut seine stimme sein so
viel soll mit gefiltert werden
dann steht das ganze über hier über
diese klinke auf linkskurs in meinen
imac über seinen usb ding überdies
mikrofone damit ist dann quasi auch
schon an der hase läuft
ich mag es einfach ein genie sprache und
zwar die sache ist einfach ich blende
euch jetzt mal foto ahlen lief bei mir
vorher aus ehrwald ich habe irgendwann
mal vor einiger zeit ein foto einfach
von meinen einstellungen macht falls ich
mal irgendwie hier das saubermachen
sollte dann verliere ich ein paar
knöpfchen einfach dass ich weiß wie die
einstellungen waren damit perfekt ist
auf diesem foto seht ihr das diese
leuchte jetzt ist das foto mal eben in
die andere ecke gerutscht oder so diese
leuchte ist grün und ich kann da nichts
dran ändern wenn ich hier den knopf
drücke geht das ding nicht auf grün
sondern es bleibt halt auch roth quasi
ich weiß nicht was das soll dass dieser
kompressor hier die ganze zeit auf rot
ist aber das ist quasi so mal probleme
wenn ich das nicht gefixt kriege kann
ich erst mal keine videos mehr aufnehmen
das regt nicht extrem auch wer nicht an
beispielsweise hier auch letztes mal
drauf klicken
und ich habe hier mikrofon 13 media usb
mikrofon das alles asb hat das ist alles
perfekt eingestellt und dann drücke ich
hier drauf drüber aufnahme laber laber
laber hier da kommt nichts an und auch
hier vorne
hier kommt auch nichts andere
normalerweise wenn ich jetzt reden würde
wird das immer so ein bisschen
ausschlagen dass ich sehe ob ich in den
roten bereich gehen oder noch im grünen
bereich
dass ich quasi während der aufnahme
genau sehen kann wie meine stimme aus
schlägt wie das ganze perfekt ich hoffe
ihr habt verstanden was mein problem ist
also quasi das eigentliche problem ist
ja hier ist nichts kaputt weil dieses
ding hier weil dem mischpult leuchten ja
wirklich alle alle knöpfchen leuchten
auch an diesem ihren dem zweiten wo das
dann noch mal drin
quasi die stelle nochmal rein kommt der
ton noch mal bearbeitet wird und dann
ist in den rechner kommt leuchtet ja
alles ist läuft alles die die lämpchen
sind an mein mikrofon hier das ist ja
nicht hingefahren und haben gelacht
sondern das liegt einfach nur diese eine
kontrollleuchte hier an dieser an diesem
kongress ording und das muss einfach auf
grün stehen damit er überhaupt etwas
ankommt weil das problem ist halt dass
hier nicht mal rein kommt weil sonst
würde dieses maß datei hier wird ja
schon ausschlagen ich sage es mal so ich
habe so viel ahnung bedingt davon dass
ich es hinkriege dass meine stimme in
den pc kommt und sich einigermaßen
vernünftig anhalt ohne dass irgendein
raum schnappt und alles mögliche das
kennt ihr ja wenn ich meine videos
schaut er beschwert sich ja eigentlich
nie jemand darüber auch koch thema neues
mikro oder sogar das läuft eigentlich
alles
und da beschwert
auch kein anderer oder wenn er mit mir
auf nimmt aber das problem ist halt so
weitergeht kann ich mir aufnehmen über
die sinnlose kompressor läuft es einfach
gut und auch wenn er jetzt so kommentare
kommen wie drückt nochmal den button
darunter oder so der eigentlich dafür
zuständig ist selbst wenn ich da drauf
ist zwar im hintergrund so eine kleine
grüne leuchte die angeht aber es bleibt
einfach so gut und ich habe keine ahnung
woran das liegt aber eventuell hat er
jemand von euch mehr ahnung von ich
würde mich da auf jeden fall extrem
darüber freuen wenn ihr mitarbeiter
helfen könntet und ihr werdet ihr
natürlich auch namentlich erwähnen und
ich überweise zehn millionen euro und
aber richtig weiß nicht jetzt wird mich
einfach mega freuen es wird nichts mehr
wundern wenn jemand von euch da wirklich
so ahnung von hat weil das wenn ich da
im internet nicht mal was drüber finde
weil sie nicht ob da jemand von euch
weiterhelfen kann aber ich dachte ihr
seid jetzt meine letzte rettung uns
würde ich sagen meine lieben freunde war
es das jetzt auch schon wieder mit dem
video für heute es tut mir leid dass
hier wieder so ein komisches hey ich
habe keinen plan wie die scheiße
funktioniert video kommt aber es muss
einfach sein und die welt quasi jetzt
meine letzte rettung weil ich nie
irgendwo irgendwie hilfe finden und es
ist heute auch sonntag
und ich kann jetzt morgen wieder zu
einem zu ihm zum tonstudio hier fahren
der nähe von hamburg und die sache ist
halt auch ich bin morgen die ganzen tag
unterwegs ich hab morgen diakonie ich
bin bei sonderausstellungen und so muss
morgen noch ein paar sachen erledigen
und ich muss eigentlich heute videos
produzieren das heißt ihr seid heute am
sonntag meine einzige rettung wie ich
das irgendwie wieder hinkriegen kann
also wenn ihr der ahnung von ab das
irgendwie meinen ton in das kompressor
mit rein kommt weil die mit funktioniert
ja alles aber wenn ich hier
normalerweise an die mikros klatsch oder
so müsste diese anzeige hier schon
längst ausschlagen und das tut es
einfach nicht deswegen ich weiß ich es
kann ja nicht an den kabel liegen
sondern es liegt einfach an diesem
kompressor leuchte dass dieser
kompression also ich hab keine ahnung
warum also
helfen können welches sehr verbunden und
jagd